listen gentlemen it is no time for our
main event of the evening
Los Angeles California it is now time
for our main event of the evening a
best-of-five heavyweight war between two
of the best arm wrestlers on the planet
introducing the participants first a
maximum-security corrections officer
competing out of Airy Pennsylvania
standing at 6 feet 2 inches tall and
weighing in at to 177 pounds with a
record of 32 wins and 3 losses he is a
multi-year wal champion and hammer
holder he is easy money day
[Applause]
[Music]
and his opponent a former member of the
Canadian Armed Forces competing on a big
island Ontario Canada
he says it's six feet five inches tall
and weighed in at to 168 pounds
it was the 2015 2016 and 2017 wala
heavyweight champion and one of only
four people to have won the wal hammer
on both arms grant a record of 33 wins
and four losses he is considered one of
the most charismatic arm wrestlers of
all time No Limits
David
[Music]
[Applause]
so Devin layer it up in his shoe game
here tonight Neil Pam I'll show you what
it is you'd like to break my shoes right
the rear ended hese worse thing is wound
tight really tight and you don't want
the good that the thing is you took a
matchup you talk about you you talk
about you that's fine but the night
comes when you got to deliver on all
that talk it's now kids on who brought
the talk to reality we're gonna find out
what I'll tell you Dave Chaffee look
it's started already closing games have
started already with Dave Chaffee when
he came out from the curtain yep looked
aggressive he looked ready he's gonna
have to survive a goal or two mind games
running the gauntlet
[Applause]
Bart would trying to get him set
best-of-five here very very important
stages of the macho's
new strat listening in to see if I could
catch any little channels from either
mum
so that solved nothing 30 seconds
expired we go to do I think he's got a
case there yeah he's just trying to keep
his in the center of the table from
where he would cause the foul on feels
like at the moment he's not getting a
fair crack of the whip in terms of
position in typical shy about backing
down but he needs to make sure he
doesn't burn up too much nervous energy
as a city hasn't actually achieved
anything yet in terms of gain in any
kind of fatigue level on the hand and
wrist of champion believe a little bit
right here towards Dave side closer you
need to get the brakes on compromise
that wrist and hand Chaffee driving
Massey drive to the center couldn't get
the pin didn't look like a pillion
Scheuer and Chaffee gets the first one
nail yeah I don't know they looked a
frank beam this may go to the video
review so left a wait and see how it
plays out I would love to see that go to
the square in the air it may we very
well may I'm gonna say we shut to book
the table here I gotta say we don't
necessarily have the best angle on that
so I really like to see that should be
square in the air yeah pivotal Paul a
hundred percent square in the air for me
they look back now I think got a match
of this magnitude you got to be that's
not a pin
yes the pin for me I mean looking at
that I don't see that as a pin at all
Bart's coming over to the review mine
she's just calling that a little bit
earlier I personally don't agree with
that at all I think that a lot of him
it looked like it was at least an inch
short for me that's not a pin I don't
know we as I say we are such a Bobby
let's look at the square in the air
let's look at the way all right they're
utilizing it Bart wants to see it see
that drives now this is the pivotal
moment any second now significance no
wait all by you Neal bury it yes if you
nobody wants to win with a referee's
decision everybody wants to win with an
arm-wrestling match so we're back to
goose eggs still on Devon yes sir bird
in many respects and Devon did manage to
compromise Dave's hand and wrist a
little there if he couldn't put the
brakes on Dave he knows that he has a
massive opportunity just clarifying the
yes one foul on Devon strap being
applied once again here their mental
approach to the game is so different
Dave Chaffee has said very little
he has devin lara has said a lot is in
to chapter 5 yep chapter 5 one of the
many things Devon leritz said prior to
this match he said Davis victorious in
the last two meetings he has called me
out dave has lived safely on the other
side of the bars
neither Locke nor Martin would protect
him at 5:04 he has my full attention
certainly does and
Rosabelle he may have had I think the
referees have got at least 20 people in
here yep look like a jump start from
Chafee when he finished it there he was
off early they're dragging each other
and it's getting a little physical oh
yeah Chafee with one pin that's your
elbow down smoldering so it is now run
nothing in favor of Dave Chaffee here
with 90 seconds for these two guys to go
to their corners yeah I'm gonna I'm
gonna be unpopular individually here but
I thought might look like a jump start
you sort of running you look a little
bit here and you've got a cup Dave
Chaffee some slack whether or not I did
to change the outcome I don't know but
he certainly either anticipated that go
very well or he moved just before he
looked like he was away early to me I'm
tight man back on the back to the table
I should say is Chaffee as the monster
Michael Todd in his corner let's take a
listen in let's eavesdrop a little bit
here I think I'd like to listen to what
the all-merciful
did you feel it went early up yeah
Devon's just a ghost he's almost
finished
I'm still trying to wind this much less
he is he loves that risk this is a man
let's just we said it before or we say
it again this is unnatural
open-palm Chaffee with a one-nothing
lead here the best-of-five and a strap
just go to the strap to this point it's
not working on de visite you know I
think I think he's playing the game as
well these are very experienced athletes
and Dave took advantage of that last set
so fiance me really well I think he got
away early but you know you pay your
money you take your chance and Deborah
couldn't get it there could not he
wanted he needs to try and get some
bullets into Dave's hand and wrist try
and put the brakes on because if it
comes to a power match there's only
gonna be one winner you're looking at
arguably the strongest man on the roster
and Dave chieffo
raw power he may not be the most
technical but horsepower he's right
there
[Music]
[Applause]
that's what he was upset with parea
Chiefy they're trying to finish he's not
been able to do so there and this is
actually good for Devon in some respect
because he wants that horsepower to be
burned to be diminished and Chaffey
every time he stretches open like that
it's actually good for Lera he comes and
connects but he can't finish
Alaric's staying with it Laurent putting
some bullets into him now and this is
the strategy that he was looking for
early he wants to try a day to make it a
battle of attrition Dave doesn't do well
here he's a dragster
have you looked at the tooth it's a
dragster against a rally car right when
it's on a straight movable and dragster
ask the speed right now the road is
going to a Dave Chaffee is feeling it
now Devon were pitting there he wants
you to pin himself he wants to embarrass
him the tables falling apart Devon's got
him they're talking about sportsmanship
there and yesterday he said I gotta feel
this baby's going a distance hey it's
one room now
but that pin if you look at right now
Devon he's holding on today though he's
trying to gas that gum out yeah and he
is unafraid to do that
he wants this much happening on now Dave
Chaffee turn to try and adjust his game
there's gonna be a very very pivotal pin
coming up because what we're about to
see here is who took the damage in that
round the attrition there on the hand
and wrist is pretty cool and as the much
progressed you saw it was almost like a
glass of confidence and Dave Chaffee
just was emptied all over yeah I'd love
to know how much lactic acid is in that
arm and a Chaffee Man mask helping him
out never looks pretty relaxed Ben he
does now things are even up at one 135
seconds remaining until Bart wood will
call them back to the table we look back
here final moments now this you noticed
at this point to the match again sort of
a critical element of the match was not
now it was before when Dave was
attacking when Dave was on the a side
but what I will say here is at that
point Devin could have finished their
did not even resist what Dave's doing
there he's tricky to Devin about his
lack of sportsmanship and Devin yeah
would have held him there all day yeah
he sort of wants to be what Dave and
visit he wants to be everything that
Dave said he was and more and look at
Dave Chaffee he is below in your hand
Lord he looks like he's just come off an
800 meter sprint struggling to get
breath Devin Lara
looks okay go oh and that highly risky
sucker race now a little bit more it is
all now and Dave is gonna need to go to
the bank now Ben I can tell you because
we're off route 1 1 here it's been an
adventure to say the least getting the
strap on these two in this match see if
where its emotions of course I'm here
that emotion wasn't what it seemed been
he was trying there to create a
situation of chaos he flies there
he likes to be in that situation he
likes to create freedom at the table
where he can move where he can utilize
that hand and wrist strategy to burn his
opponent he knows that they chafe is
stronger but he also knows that it's
almost boxer against the puncture he
knows that if he can put miles on Dave's
quarter then he has the advantage he
said well he's about to do so I think
Dave TV has tried to pull a tint Lou
he's dropped right now under the table
he's trying to win this with body weight
and devil Eric just smile at her Devin
connects in Dave's shadow come up will
engage a press he's going for it like
never before but Devin is working very
hard here believe me he's trying to
climb and he's trying to bounce Dave
back David just kidding himself he needs
to watch that or take pressure there but
he's higher is the sacrifice and then
deliver he's baiting it he's talking to
him three fouls
and it's again for Devin and Devin
wasn't attacking back there yeah he was
letting Dave feel like he was in the
match he was letting Dave attacked and
burst his energy wide open Davis very
long left now they were mocking him
because he utilized Mike's all move that
y'all move up
[Applause]
so Devin Larrick went away from closing
this out in four you know both take a 90
second break here in their corners a
very ugly affair emotionally charged but
when we see this on the replay look at
the face of devil Eric he's got a huge
smile all over it because he knows that
all the disparate elements that go to
make up Dave Chaffee weapons his primary
assault are already damaged they're
already burned and you can see that big
smile he's not trying to finish Dave
there he's trying to give him false hope
great pictures by our camera operators
standing work by them this Devin closing
out who knew yes I think he does mate I
think I think right now Devin is in a
pivotal position and and it's going to
be interesting to see how Devin actually
reacts now I really don't feel like Dave
can can take a match from here and the
loving to prove me wrong and get a feel
of it because then it goes the duration
but I'll tell you what it is that
demeanor there from Dave that laughing
smiling joking demeanor yeah tells a
story tells a story because he hasn't
wanted to joke there's been no play time
no but right now he's rolled over a
little and he's shown his throat yeah
Devin Laurent will jump on that yep he's
a pit bull he wants to finish and I
wonder what Devin's gonna do now he was
very very upset by the comments to Dave
Chaffee leading up to this match
certainly was Willie now River Willie go
back to being more sporting or will he
try to embarrass Dave now because I
think he's got the feel ability to do
that I'd love Dave to prove me wrong but
I just think he's really strong yeah
doesn't arm wrestle well in the home
torn out battles it's not his game who
said he's a dragster he's better at his
whole career
he's Dave looking to get away to get a
breather to shake down all mounting to
get his breath he's sweating heavily
Devon's calling him on you've got no
time young ya nominated strap the time
out we're going there and you know it's
a the best chance Dave's got with the
strap yeah he can use at least the arm
strength but I think a lot of it's good
it's almost like the dragster nose
bicycle tires on all that power is gonna
be burned into the ether you can know
what you're getting down it's Devon or
its world never now more relaxed he's
not fighting with the referees he feels
like he's in a position where he doesn't
need to do that he can get what he needs
in the match he's calm now he created
the situation that he could thrive in he
created a situation that allowed him to
burnout Dave Chaffee and now he's calm
he's almost cocky there will be millions
and hundreds of thousands of ways that
he could finish now but I think he may
just make this a very long horrible
affair say if you're trying to stay
alive huge drive for an inmate but if
you look at Devon's face all that panic
stop it on Devon Scotland's actually
yeah yes to gain position yeah and
that's not intentionally stood to gain a
squad
Devon talking to you
adjust this position very very oddly
much to allow deaden the opportunity to
pin him he looked for the way out and
fold himself out of the match yeah
unfortunate ending for Chafee Devin
Lehren wins it 3-1
after words had been exchanged for the
last few weeks turned into a
disappointingly ugly affair at a table
mate but yeah when you look at that
replay as soon as the match started and
Devin sacrificed that hand and wrist
Dave was in a world of trouble and when
you're in that situation it's very very
hard to get back and Devin started to
work he's mind they're starting to
embarrass him this is a proud man he
didn't want that and he looked for the
way out and found it he did down a
Jason's on Fisher standing by with Dave
Chaffee easy money Dave Chaffee you guys
put on a show here tonight this is the
first time that Devin was able to beat
you what was the difference here tonight
he came in prepared fired up I did too
he liked it he came in real strong
powerful he was better tonight I give
him credit bad dude right there well
speaking of bad dude you you guys have
shared some bad words before this I mean
there's been a lot of talk how much was
that in your head and how much were you
trying to get in his head tonight before
this match it's a little Bowl that fired
me up the stuff I said fired him up but
we're friends after the table now so
it's all good all right well what's next
for you easy money Dave Chaffee you're
still one of the best to ever do it
we'll see what happens hopefully I get
another call from WL maybe September who
knows we'll see
all right well everyone give it up one
more time for Dave Chaffee easy money
and keep it going for your Victor here
tonight
no limits Devon Lehren hey Devon it was
that was not easy at all I mean you are
soaking wet you are dripping in sweat
how hard did you have to work for this
victory here tonight ah you know David
he's stronger he just says he's stronger
I had to I had to use all the ugliness
that arm wrestling has to offer
all right this sport you've got to be
willing to put it all out there you got
to be willing to go to the line okay I'm
I'm willing to go all the way and this
match is like this matches was
everything for me it's I'm speechless
how you had never beaten Dave Chaffee
before in your entire career you've done
so much you've accomplished so much what
does this win here tonight mean to you
Dave Chaffee all around the world is
recognized Dave Chaffee is gone to
Europe he's beaten the top guys I just
recently went to Europe and faced one of
the strongest men in the world Dennis
the plank off and like most you know I
got killed Dave dave has a win on Dennis
so for me this is just a step closer to
where I want to be well like I said to
easy money there was a lot of talk
before this match he said that you don't
respect your opponents you try to get in
their head but I hear a lot of respect
for Dave Chaffee after this match coming
from you well you know I love this sport
I love I love the feelings that it gives
me today in this life you know you can
get material wealth you can get all
sorts of things but the real treasure I
think is these feelings and to me this
is a feeling I'll treasure forever
that's amazing well this is a feeling I
think we all will treasure forever thank
you for putting on a great show tonight
you gave your all and we appreciate it
that was an amazing match thanks wal
thanks Dave Chaffee see you guys soon